what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another interview for one of
my favorite shows on TV right now Richie
Moriarty for ghosts I've said this to
you many times but I have to keep saying
it because this show just keeps
brightening my day congratulations oh
thanks so much I'm so glad you're
enjoying it it's been so fun to make so
we always love hearing that people are
enjoying it too you feel it that feeling
is infectious I love watching this
Ensemble more than anything so I have a
couple of of random I'm calling them
rapid fire they're not rapid fire some
of these will take you some time to
answer but just a couple of random
questions to get to know you a little
bit more beginning with one of my
favorite acting questions to ask what is
your absolute favorite part of the
acting process rehearsing putting your
costume on for the first time but then I
also want the opposite not necessarily
your least favorite but a part of the
process where you either see Room to
Grow for yourself or an opportunity to
try something new yeah but both really
good questions I think my favorite part
of the acting process is like the first
take on a new project because it's I
love meeting you know to me acting is
all about The Ensemble and the people
we're doing it with but it's really
really fun to see both I guess in the
first rehearsal and in the first take
how your scene partners are going to
play the scene and I feel like there are
always pleasant surprises and a really
nice window into how your performers
approach the work so I I love that part
of it
um the thing that's obviously a bummer
you know especially even with ghosts is
being away from home you know like as
wonderful as Montreal is and as much as
we love being up there and making the
show it's hard we're gone from home for
half the year so the logistics of that
especially when you have little kids
like I do is tricky
um so I think like you know the the more
I do this kind of work the more I
understand why it's stressful on
families you know
um so yeah that's that's the most
difficult part very very understandable
I want to follow up on your first answer
to that that big old compound question
there do you remember your very first
take on the ghost set and I don't know
what kind of expectations did that leave
you with and then how did it compare to
your experience moving forward gosh
that's such a good question I'm trying
to remember the first thing we shot in
the pilot
I think the for the first thing we ever
shot for ghosts was uh Asher grodman who
plays Trevor Has a a speech in the pilot
where he's talking about this like epic
birthday party the tarot read birthday
party that he went to uh and he's sort
of standing in front of all of us in the
living room and we're all listening to
him you know Regale us and I think I
introduce him as like you know today the
talk of the week is being given by
Trevor and then he comes up and talks
about like this Tara Reid birthday party
but I but I remember it being so
exciting because like it's you know
first of all I had no idea how Asher was
going to play Trevor I've only seen
Trevor on the page I've only seen any of
these characters on the page so it was
just really cool because everyone chimes
in and interrupts his story and you got
you got an immediate sense for like what
this world was gonna feel like with
these ghosts from very different
backgrounds and time periods and how we
were going to sort of meld as a group
and um I'm sure you've heard some of us
talk about this too but we had such a an
interesting entree into shooting the
pilot typically your cast you go to La
you're shooting a pilot within like
weeks of you know it's a very short
process it can be very fast and we went
out to shoot the pilot two days before
March 13th 2020. so like we were out
there getting ready in our in our
costumes you know perfecting wardrobe
since we're going to be in this same
wardrobe every day of the show and uh
then we were sent home before we shot a
single thing so we had this weird
eight-month period of time where
we were sort of like you know on text
chains with each other constantly as a
cast and and you know getting on Zoom
you know every couple weeks to kind of
check in with each other but we really
bonded as as a group going through this
weird pandemic experience and this
experience of like booking what felt
like a dream job and then hoping like
heck that it wasn't going to go away and
disappear so by the time we actually got
to shoot the pilot in December of 2020
we were all friends you know we all felt
like we really had a connection aside
from a couple people who joined us very
last minute in the cast most of us were
there you know with each other for eight
months kind of supporting each other
through this craziness so that was a
very I think beneficial thing for us in
that we we were able to bond before we
even got to shoot something so it was a
really I think it contributed a lot to
the sort of chemistry that we have I'm
ruining my little game with many
follow-up questions but something you
just brought up a little earlier made me
curious which character change the most
from your initial read of the script to
What that particular actor brought to
the role on set oh man that's such a
good question
um
I think you know gosh like I I I'm
literally like going through the cast in
my head and every single person
surprised me in different ways
um I I I was at UCB at the same time
that Brandon Scott Jones was in New York
before we booked ghosts so I knew of him
he and I you know probably talked a
handful of times but we're not we're not
friends but I you know really respected
him and loved him as an improviser and
really enjoyed watching him on stage at
UCB and it was really really fun to see
what he brought to Isaac
um because there were a couple I
actually tested for the role of Pete on
the same day that other actors were
testing for Isaac and so I saw the
potential other people who would have
played Isaac and they would have been so
vastly different you know great probably
for in many ways but just different so
it it's always so interesting to to see
you know who steps into a role and how
they make it singularly theirs you know
Alberta you know Danielle was not the
original choice for Alberta that that
casting changed over the pandemic
because of conflicts and I think all the
time about how drastically different it
would have been to not have Danielle who
is just so magnificent in that role to
not have her be Alberta you know it's
it's fascinating and like Roman Roman
was cast relatively last minute you know
he was cast like I think the week we
shot the pilot in December and you know
I think about that all the time too he's
become like a family member basically
and is just so outstanding in that role
so uh you know it's it's I think
everybody is just incredible at what
they do and they make it singularly
theirs it's so true you feel it when
you're watching it I have to now pit the
family against one another because I'm
going to keep bringing this topic up
because I'm obsessed with Scrabble and I
love hearing about how like brutal your
Scrabble competition got and when I was
talking to her Rebecca about it she told
me that you were especially good at
Scrabble so now I need to know who was
your biggest competition who was like
number two on the most competitive list
oh man uh probably Danielle Danielle is
a fierce competitor uh she's very good
but she's also like when I beat her
she's mad at me
you know she does not let let things go
easily so I have to be very careful with
how I approach Danielle after a Scrabble
win uh and I really have to credit my
dad my dad and I have played Scrabble
since the time I was like 10. like he he
kind of used Scrabble as a way to like
talk about words and vocabulary and like
the roots of words we kind of used it a
lot around like s.a.t prep time too he
used it as like a nerdy way to like get
into you know the definitions of words
and he's my dad is an incredible
Scrabble player better than I am uh and
he I love playing with him he and I
always have great games that go into so
yeah I gotta credit my dad for the
Scrabble skills this follow-up question
might be taking a step too far but who
of the ghost cast was the worst at
Scrabble oh man there's always I feel
like in every group when you bring up
Scrabble there's always one person who's
like oh yeah I'm I'm amazing at Scrabble
and uh they're not um I think I'm trying
to remember you know what I'm gonna call
Devin out it's Devin it's thorfin uh Dev
I think immediately upon starting to
play with me he he's so competitive he's
like you know he used to be we used to
play football he's competitive in
everything he does he's competitive and
we play ping pong on set but when he
realized that he wasn't gonna easily
beat me in many games he got very mad uh
and he's since gotten a lot better but I
think he realized like oh no these
people are playing on a different level
yeah if you if you say you're good at
Scrabble
you better you better live up to the
hype that you're building for yourself
all right I want to ask you a personal
question based on Little Pete's
obsession with Pete's handbook I want to
know the the book the movie the show
that you yourself know so well that if
anyone made even the slightest change to
it you would pick up on it yeah I mean
you know what that like this is so
strange there there are a lot of things
there are a lot of like cultural
touchstones but I'll give you I'll give
you a couple I feel like Saturday Night
Live is just always going to be an
answer I still I don't think I've ever
missed an episode of Saturday Night Live
in my lifetime and I've watched plenty I
have like season one box set you know uh
in my in my living room so like when
Lorraine Newman joined us for an episode
what a joy to like have her on set with
us but SNL has always been a touchstone
for me and like always been something
that is like where I think I found my
comedic voice you know when I found
these like weirdos who were writing
these insane sketches and acting in
these insane sketches I think it really
it was a big part of uh my comedy
development
um the movie for me that I've probably
seen the most is Goodwill Hunting
so I went to school I went to college in
Boston I lived in Boston for about 15
years
and Goodwill Hunting uh I think came out
in 98
which was my senior year in high school
but then like by the time I got to
college it was on we had like a college
Movie Channel and it was just always on
our College Movie Channel because we
were we were in Boston it had just won
the Oscar it was like this thing so like
every night when I'd come home at the
end of the day with my friends who I
lived with we would watch Goodwill
Hunting and we I've probably seen it 75
times and can quote that movie backwards
and forwards so that is uh one of those
weird that's my Pete's handbook is uh
the Goodwill Hunting script uh you give
me any scene and I can quote it to death
that is an excellent choice I love that
especially because I have air on the
brain and uh Matt Damon just like that
it's so good
it's so good I was astonished for like
we have to talk real quick about
um Christmas Cena playing the agent I
mean outstanding like everyone's
everyone is so outstanding and at
Christmasy and it blew me away uh Matt
Damon's so good at it Jason Bateman a
perfect I mean he's perfect he's so good
in it just like what a great what a
great film I really enjoyed it Chris
Messina is one of those actors that I
will always think never gets the credit
he deserves for making so much out of
every ounce of screen time he gets in
roles like that truly and that was the
perfect example he's like on the he's on
the other end of a phone for most of the
movie but he is like just Crush like
stealing scenes in whatever way you can
when literally your scene partner isn't
in the room with you I was just so
impressed with what he did in that film
what do you know how they shot that no
they they actually shot that where I
believe Matt Damon was like in the Next
Room over so they could be performing
the scene together and when I heard that
I'm like why isn't every phone
conversation totally shot that way it's
so frustrating to shoot scenes like that
when when they aren't because like
oftentimes you'll have like a script
supervisor reading the other end and
depending on who the script supervisor
is you're not getting a lot of energy
back so you know to yeah to I mean
brilliant move it's so nice to have
somebody to truly play off of especially
when like you you're gonna feed off of
their energy and play opposite that
energy so yeah it's uh that's a
brilliant way to do that doesn't
surprise me they did it that way all
right I have one more sillier question
because I think I asked this to the
other group at San Diego Comic-Con and I
just I kind of love this thought so
let's say you as in real you you move
into a house a man or whatever and there
are ghosts there you need to tell
somebody in your life who do you tell
about the ghost that will actually
believe you that they're really there I
think assuming I'm living with my wife
and she's also experiencing the ghosts
in the scenario uh I think I'm telling
my sister
my sister I think is one of those people
that just like implicitly trusts me uh
and would actually
believe the insane story that I I was
telling her uh my my parents my mom
would be hilarious my mom would be like
oh please oh please she you know she
wouldn't buy buy it per second my dad uh
my dad I don't know I bet he's a bit of
a skeptic too uh but yeah my sister I
think my sister I could get on board are
you an older sibling I am a younger
sibling I have an older sister named
Colleen who's like my number one fan and
just the best she's the best she and her
family are some of uh the the dearest
people in my life I was gonna say
because I have a younger sibling and I
feel like I can get her to believe
absolutely anything but I think I'm just
like throwing the older sibling weight
around in a way that I've kind of earned
over the years so oh yeah my sister did
the same my sister threw that weight
around all the time like wouldn't even
let me walk through doorways she'd be
like what's the password and I'm like
what are we doing here you know just a
nightmare a nightmare when we were
younger and now now we're like best
friends I identify with everything you
just said way too much yeah all right
going back to the very beginning of your
ghost journey briefly what would you say
is the biggest difference between how
you first pictured Pete when you first
got your very first script maybe shot
the pilot compared to who he turned out
to be when you finally got the chance to
shoot the rest of the season this is a
this is a great question because I have
like a very clear story here they're
like in the casting process I went in
this was like you know pre-pandemic so
we went in in person to the CBS building
in New York and I and I read for the
role with uh with the casting director
and I read the scenes that I was given
once as I interpreted the character
and then their only note to me was like
great let's do one more and just make it
bigger just go bigger with with it and
so I did another version that was like
way bigger bigger energy probably closer
to the peat you're seeing on screen
today and when I got the call that they
wanted me to fly to Los Angeles to test
for the role I had to ask I said hey I
said to my manager I said could you ask
them which take they preferred because I
did two very different reads on this
character and um so my manager went back
to the casting and casting said the
second take the bigger take so I was
like great and it's funny because like
when I I forget if this was when I was
testing or if it was right before we
shot the pilot but Joe Port one of the
showrunners said to me he said hey we've
been using Ned Flanders as like a
touchstone for this character like we
imagine this guy is very flanders-esque
and again that wasn't I was seeing him
much more as kind of my dad who's a
little more understated and smaller
still like chipper and happy but not
quite Flanders level
so that really informed how I played it
because like you know anytime you hear
from the showrunner like hey this is how
we're envisioning a thing it's like goal
great let me you know see that see your
vision to fruition as much as I can so I
think you know Pete is much more uh I
guess like
there's just like he's turned up to 11.
he's he is Flanders in a lot of ways
um so yeah that's it's definitely a more
Amplified version of what I was first
seeing little Flanders with a whole lot
of warmth though totally totally all
right taking a step further now so we we
were talking a little bit about this at
Comic-Con but I'm curious for your
answer in season two in particular I was
I was asking you if there were any
particular scenes that redefined the
character the most for you where every
scene you shot after you found being
influenced by that particular scene you
had mentioned the moment in season one
when he found out that his wife had been
cheating on him is there a moment that
had that same effect on you for the
character in season two now obviously
stopping short of the episode that is
being revealed this week uh ghost Father
of the Bride yeah I mean yeah because
there definitely is a moment in ghost
Father of the Bride but I think there
the scene where the Ghost Hunter scene
where
um where flower and thorfin end up in
the ghost trap and basically thorphin
ends up in there because Pete chickens
out and doesn't want to touch the Trap
and Pete had does have to have this like
come to Jesus moment where he's like hey
are you going to sacrifice yourself to
save your friends or Are You Gonna Stand
By and Watch idly while they potentially
perish uh so that was a that was a big
scene I think for Pete you know like
Pete over the course of season two
especially has like learned lessons but
seemingly forgot them very quickly and
like there's he's been on this roller
coaster of like figuring out how to
truly stand up for himself and get some
gumption and actually like do the hard
work of of being a good friend and you
know supporting the people around you so
I think that was a really defining
moment for him where he kind of said
okay like I'm gonna go into this ghost
trap I don't know what's gonna happen
but it's time for me to step up I love
that episode all right I have one more
big broad question before I focus just
on ghost father the bride here yeah I
love talking about the value of a good
scene partner and I know it might be
hard to come up with just one answer to
this question but can you give me an
example of a Time on set when a scene
partner you had made all the difference
where you know if they weren't there
giving you what you needed you wouldn't
have been able to reach something impede
or just Crush something you had to do in
a particular scene yeah I mean Rose
McIver comes to mind uh immediately Rose
is so good at what she does and she's
such a supportive scene partner and
there's a scene I think it is in the
Pete's Wife episode where I'm basically
trying to convince her I show her where
the manual is there's a manual like
hidden in the pantry and we have this
scene where I'm I'm saying I'm basically
saying like look get that manual up
there use this to get my wife back to
the mansion so that I can see my family
and it is kind of a last resort for Pete
and he's really begging and the energy
that Rose gives back in that scene you
know as Sam she's just like
I don't know there are certain there are
certain performers who totally change
your approach to a scene like I can have
an idea of how I want to play a scene
but then when I when I saw the way she
was playing that scene she plays it so
sweetly and so earnestly and she re like
you can feel in her face that she has a
relationship with this guy now and she
wants to help him and I think it really
changed my performance in that scene and
uh I just I adore Rose and I love I love
that like she's the you know our number
one and she's such such a wonderful tone
uh with us and she has such a hard job
in this show it is so difficult doing
what she does but she does it so well
there's such a beautiful answer I love
that so much thanks all right the time
has come I'm gonna put up the spoiler
warning particularly for ghost Father of
the Bride which when this interview is
released everyone can watch it on
Paramount plus if you haven't watched it
on CBS go check it out you just push
pause on this video you go watch the
episode then you come right back push
play and it begins right here it is that
easy all right so digging into some
particular moments here one thing that I
really loved was was the urgency that
Pete had in this episode and and how his
frustration comes out like for example
when he gets into the kitchen with Sam
he like he's really aggravated that none
of his ideas were approved and it was
making me wonder do you think that
frustration comes mostly with you know
him butting heads with his with his ex
his ex-wife with Carol and the lasting
resentment that came from her having
cheated on him or is it more so driven
by like a genuine desperation that his
daughter could have the wedding of her
dreams I think it's certainly a
combination of both I mean like Pete is
definitely I think with some distance
he's now has like 40 years since he was
a married man and especially in this
like wedding planning process with his
ex-wife he's being reminded minded of
all the reasons why this was not a great
relationship you know he was not in a
marriage that worked that well there was
a lot of sniping when they were alive
and there's even sniping now that he's
dead and like you know I think there's a
lot of frustration there especially
because he's he is seeing some of these
moments as like a barrier to potentially
having the wedding that he wants to have
for his daughter some of it too is just
frustration of being dead right like he
wants to be able to voice these things
to the people that can actually affect
the change so I think a lot of it too is
just that frustration of like not being
fully present in the way that people who
are living are
um and then of course he adores his
daughter more than anything in the world
so he he wants to be able to share this
moment with her and when it seems like
that slipping through his fingers he's I
think terrified and really sad you know
um to think that there is an opportunity
to potentially see your daughter get
married when you're dead is is like
incredible to him and to see that
potentially slipping away I think is
heartbreaking so so yeah there are a lot
a lot of different frustrations there
but I think it is it's like it's the
wife it's being dead in general and you
know potentially losing this opportunity
with his daughter so bringing up being
dead in general and the answer to this
question might just be a flat out no and
I've thought about this throughout this
series but in particular I like I felt
myself like wanting to reach for
something like this in this moment for
him have have you all and and the
showrunners and the writers ever come
anywhere close to letting another living
in on the ghost's secret and then maybe
kind of pulled back and veered back in
the other direction which goes secret
like the the idea that there are ghosts
in the manner like where where's Sam and
Jay tell another person so that a ghost
can indeed interact with a living in
some sense or more so than they have
been we you know there there have
certainly been moments where I think
potentially we we've wanted to say like
wouldn't she just tell them
but I think there is right now she's
only told Bala right like uh Jay's
sister so she's the only one that sort
of has a window into this and that
didn't necessarily go great when she
first told her so I think there is this
like real fear that she can that you
know Sam can be seen as a woman who is
unstable and not well uh When what when
we'd potentially tell people this but I
I do I do feel like you know I hope this
show has a long life and I do feel like
there is a lot of fun to be had in that
Revelation and in revealing that to
different people in the ghost universe
so I feel like it will happen I don't
think we've seen the last of that reveal
of her you know sort of Supernatural
ability
um because I feel like there's just a
lot of fun to be had there so I wouldn't
be surprised if we see more of that in
the future I feel like I'd be the
absolute worst in Sam's shoes and I
wouldn't be able to help myself and just
blab to everyone and that probably
caused some problems
I think about that all the time like if
it were me in my life I would be like
I'm seeing ghosts I'm seeing ghosts
everywhere like I'd be just like fully
screaming it to the to the rooftops
if if you had your your choice and you
could have one living character that's
appeared on the show be in the know in
this sense who would you pick why and
maybe How could an interaction with Pete
influence him for the better gosh that's
such a good question
um I feel like it's especially hard for
you to answer because there are so many
family members in play now I know like
Peter you can only pick one which one
he's in a unique situation that way like
you know I I would say Carol but I I
don't think that would go well uh having
Pete's wife
be fully in on the secret again
he doesn't really get along with his
wife so maybe it is Laura you know maybe
the the actress that plays Laura um is
her name is Holly Gautier Frankel she's
so great she's so great in this episode
it was so it's always so nice to have
like she she had a really small part in
the Pete's Wife episode in season one
you know like great kind of guest star
that comes in and and does a you know
it's the hardest job in in TV is like
being a guest star or a co-star and
coming in and doing one small scene
because like you're waiting all day for
it there's all this build up you don't
really know how the show functions and
she she knocked that out of the park in
that episode and to see her get
something a little meteor in this
episode it's always so nice especially
like from a series regular perspective
to see someone who you can totally you
know like I was there not too many years
ago like doing those guest stars and
co-stars and like trying to find my
footing and she's just so good and it
was so nice to have her back to to do
more so yeah maybe like that would be
really fun uh to and you know she even
says in this episode like I feel dad's
presence here so maybe she would be
someone who'd be a little more
susceptible to like believing Sam and
and understanding the situation so yeah
I'll say I'll say Laura I wouldn't mind
seeing that happen so bringing her up
and also going back to an idea that I
brought up a couple of times during this
episode The the moment where he gets to
walk her down the aisle that is a pretty
significant life moment there so to
tease what's to come maybe at the end of
this season and what lies ahead for Pete
how do you think that that particular
experience is going to change him going
forward man I think like
you know the nice thing about seeing
that scene on the page and getting to
perform it is that like
we all have experiences where we've
either been to weddings of friends or
gotten married ourselves and haven't
been able to have loved ones with us
um you know my my wife's mom wasn't able
to come to our wedding because she was
too sick to travel and she actually
passed away the day after we got married
and they there are I think like real
significant moments like that for
everybody so to be able to sort of play
out this fantasy in a lot of ways where
you know even though your loved one has
passed you know we all hope they're
there in presence somehow so to be able
to sort of like show that you know show
what so many people hope for I think in
moments like that was really so cool and
I think I I you know I hope that that
moment for Pete brings a lot of closure
in in a lot of ways for his family you
know like again these moments when his
family are at the Mansion are so special
and critical and give him and give him a
window into this world that continues
without him but in that scene you know
he was able to be part of it again for a
minute you know even though he's like
yelping in pain for half of it because
he's linking his arm with hers but yeah
I think there's real you know that's one
of those Monumental Life moments that
you think about like being able to see
your kids get married and to for him to
be able to be a part of that I think was
really special and hopefully provided
some some closure for him and his uh you
know relationship with his daughter
bringing up the linking of the arms I
feel like I can ask this question about
any scene in this show what is it like
kind of figuring out figuring out that
right balance between that that
sentimental heartfelt quality but also
still being able to earn a laugh because
probably said this to all of you a
million times at this point but your
ability to balance and switch back and
forth is just absolutely impeccable and
I feel like shouldn't work as well as it
does no it really shouldn't especially
with 21 minute long episodes like it
doesn't make any sense that they're able
to pull it off as well as they do so
many times I think you know like the
bulk of the credit has to go to Joe port
and Joe Eisman our show Runners because
like tonally that's such a difficult
thing to have a network sitcom also be
able to pull at heartstrings and shift
that kind of energy in such a short time
period incredibly difficult to do I
think a lot of credit goes to our
directors too you know Jake Harris who
directed this episode talked a lot with
me about that moment of walking down the
aisle and he in conjunction with the
Joes that we we shot that walking down
the aisle many different ways one where
Pete was just basically half a step
behind her and like with her and you
know very emotional but walking behind
her and then the other one where I'm
linking with her the whole time and sort
of like yelping in pain the whole time
and in the final edit they really
Blended those two together where like
the first half of it is me kind of with
her but not you know linked with her and
then you know it's kind of a nice
transition where he's like ah screw it
like I'm gonna do the traditional thing
and link my arm with her and finish this
so I think tonally too you know and Jay
even said this as he was directing it
was he's like we're gonna see how this
plays because it may be that we see the
edit and the best thing for this is just
going to be this straight sentimental
you know moment of you being behind her
but if we can punctuate it with a little
of the humor of you linking arms with
her and that really hurting you then
we'll do it and so I I think you know
the editors Everybody Plays such a
critical role in this and and our
special effects people too like they had
to figure out how can we how can we link
arms and make it look like we're really
linking arms even though we're not so
the the whole thing just was very
impressive how it came together I was
really excited to see that it came
together so well it is really something
else I'm endlessly impressed by how you
and the team do things like that I'll
end with this one here so now limiting
it to the main Ensemble of characters of
everybody in the cast who do you think
Pete would have the most to gain from at
this point in his after life which other
character do you think he'd benefit from
spending more time with in season three
I feel like he and Isaac have we have a
lot more to explore with uh his
relationship with Isaac I Isaac in a lot
of ways you know sees himself as the
leader of this group of ghosts he's the
you know the general the commander and I
think Pete also sees himself that way as
like the Scout Troop leader it's a
different leader energy but similar and
I think like the two of them together
have a lot to uh to explore and
potentially like work toward both of
their advantages in the house and I'd
say like the same about Rebecca wasaki
too and hedy's character like I think
Pete and Hedy we haven't explored a lot
of their relationship and it will be
really interesting I think to dive down
deeper into into the two of them and how
they operate together and what that
relationship really is I love that you
literally could have said anyone and I
would have been sitting here going yes
yes more of that please I'm like going
through the Rolodex and I'm like flower
I mean flower all day like you know like
I could I could say about anybody but
yeah it's part of the joy of an ensemble
like this right is like we we even two
seasons in there is so much left to
explore especially amongst the ghosts
you know flashing back to their past in
the house like show me what 25 years ago
was like in the house with Pete and Hedy
and Sass you know like what were they
going through like we've clearly been
going through a lot in this house and
we're only we've only really scratched
the surface with our relationship so I'm
excited to you know learn more about
these ghost relationships I want to see
it all I want to see it all I have to
let you go but I'm gonna say huge
congratulations on ghost and thank you
because having a show that consistently
puts a smile on my face like this show
does is very very important pretty much
always but it feels like especially now
in challenging times I need ghosts in my
life congratulations and thank you for
your time today thank you so much and
thank you for being such a nice support
for the show we're very grateful and
always love chatting with you